had an 11-point lead in Game one named
shoe is a wire-to-wire victory for
Golden State
Kevin Durant's first shot is good when
the ball reverses he ready to make plays
hurry from downtown mrs. Duran snatches
the rebound away from loved banks in the
follow John Livingston in the game for
Golden State as well Durant from beyond
the arc rattles home and all of a sudden
Golden State quickly within to the ramp
to handle the crossover the pull-up
shots good and they've come back to take
to tie the game at 26 with 30 seconds
remaining love 15 points 9 rebounds
Durant's shot is good a free quarter for
Kevin Durant he's been a nice boost for
Terron Lew he's talented now offensively
[Applause]
kevin durand guys who haven't played
much I'm gonna come and double this
Durant fires a three knocks it down
Kevin Durant with eight Spence of a
second the remaining draymond Green is
one man to beat throws it back to Durant
steps into a three and knocks it down
Kevin Durant with 27
a sin sided Iran beautiful whooping and
draymond Green with his seventh assist
but that's the luxury for the Warriors
stars they don't have to always play
great Duran gets the bounce and has the
mismatch on him it's George Hill waiting
for some space rises and scores Kevin
Durant torching the Cavaliers he's got
34 he's 6 of 8 from the field 4 rebounds
as a blocked shot
Durant Rises and connects he has been
scalding tonight playoff high for hood
in this 2018 postseason Durant again
Kevin Durant's got 38 Iran goes to Kevin
lone pulls up jumper got it Kevin Durant
with 40 shot clock at five
Kevin Durant way outside delivers Kevin
Durant from downtown that's a six-point
game